today on the matt wall show big tech has
begun banning accounts who they say are
inciting violence against medical
clinics that butcher and castrate
children but if criticism is incitement
then aren't we as conservatives victims
of it also or is that not how it works
plus public health authorities finally
admit that monkey pox is a sexually
transmitted disease this raises some
extremely disturbing questions about the
pets and children that have contracted
it also mike pence calls on
conservatives to stop attacking the fbi
he is missing the point and i'll explain
why pediatricians speak out anonymously
against the transing of kids in our
daily cancellation students at the
university of virginia want all mention
of their school's founder erased we'll
talk about all that and more today on
the matt walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
i want to talk to you about american
financing america's home for home loans
because i really think that you could
benefit from one of their 10-minute
mortgage reviews it's a free
no-obligation conversation around your
current loan your other debts and even
buying a new home you can talk about
whatever you want to talk about with
your salary-based mortgage consultant
because they're focused on you not on
getting a commission let them run the
numbers for you and see if they can save
you up to a thousand dollars a month if
they can you can move forward with a new
custom loan and start saving more today
american financing is a family-owned
business there's no pressure there's no
obligation there's no upfront or hidden
fees it's worth the call to learn more
and look you can't afford to not call
because we're all looking for ways to
save money and this is the way to do it
call 866-569-4711
call them right now and start saving
money immediately that again is
866-569-4711 or you can simply visit
americanfinancing.net nmls
182-334-nmlsconsumeraccess.org
in april of last year dan frankel a
member of the pennsylvania house of
representatives sat down for an
interview with dr gerald montano who's
the medical director of the gender and
sexuality development program at upmc
children's hospital of pittsburgh he's
also the assistant professor of
pediatrics at the university of
pittsburgh school of medicine so that's
his whole resume quite extensive um and
it was a 20-minute discussion that
covered a wide range of questions all
related to the sort of gender affirming
care
offered to children at the hospital now
oddly enough
uh the video was posted to youtube last
year on the pennsylvania house of
representatives youtube channel but then
it was unlisted and when you unlist a
video it means that it won't pop up
during a search on the site which means
that nobody will see it unless they go
directly to your channel and if your
channel is the pennsylvania house of
representatives channel that means well
nobody will see it at all
and nobody did until i found it
yesterday and posted it to twitter now
the video is relevant uh this week
especially as the media and the left run
around pulling their hair out accusing
conservatives like myself and many
others of harassing and inciting
violence against gender clinics and
children's hospitals by they say
making up stories about children being
medically transitioned this is all
something that we're making up it's uh
it's invented it's false it's
misinformation and yet up until these
establishments started getting public
blowback about all these procedures they
were quite open and upfront about what
they were doing
as you can hear in this video dr montano
lays out in detail how children begin to
socially transition quote unquote at
five and then medically transition at
ten followed by in some cases surgery
before they turn 18.
listen
what does gender affirming care look
like for a five-year-old and then maybe
for a ten-year-old that's another good
question so for a five-year-old there is
no medical intervention for a
five-year-old because none is necessary
what we do for a five-year-old is that
we refer them to a therapist to help
them explore their gender identity and
to make them feel comfortable with how
they feel about themselves
now for a ten-year-old that really
depends on where they are in puberty
because for some people especially those
who are assigned female at birth they
might start having
signs of puberty and then there is
discussion on whether or not pubertal
blockers may be warranted for that
individual because they can become
really distressed if they're starting to
develop secondary sex characteristics
that really distresses them so it really
depends on where they are in puberty at
10 years old when would hormone therapy
tend to be introduced and how do we know
that that's safe
so another good question so according to
the endocrine society guidelines for
working with transsexual individuals
they recommend that the age is 16.
there's a lot of discussion about
surgical options
when does that become part of the
discussion
and do all trans people seek surgery
another good question and so
for
depending on the top surgery but for the
vast majority of surgeries
they are not done until the youth is 18
years old
the only exception is top surgery in
which sometimes that is done earlier and
again that is a intensely personal
decision
between the child the family and the
doctor and the surgeon and the mental
health provider
to see if that is the right path towards
them
an intensely personal decision whether
the child
is going to have her breast chopped off
he's actually he's still not telling the
full truth there he says the only
exception when it comes to surgeries on
minors is uh top surgery so-called top
surgery that's not true they're they do
all kinds of other surgeries um on on
kids as well
but even if it was just top surgery that
would certainly be bad enough now we can
expect that the video i just played
there will be promptly deleted just as
gender clinics and children's hospitals
around the country are right now
this week frantically deleting all of
the material that they had once proudly
published advertising their treatment of
children including extremely young
children here's another likely soon to
be deleted video this from the director
of the yale pediatric gender program
extolling her program's benefits for
children as young as three years old in
her case
so i'm a clinical psychologist by
training and i am the director of the
yale gender program which is an
interdisciplinary program
working with gender expansive
individuals 3 to 25 and their families
we
help individuals who are questioning
their gender identity or who identify as
transgender non-binary we help them
with their gender journey thinking
through that thinking through the risks
and the benefits of
medical intervention
starting medical intervention um and
also building supports around them i
love what i do so it's really really
wonderful to
to be working in this field and to be
working with individuals who are gender
diverse and gaining their support and
helping them on their gender journeys
now
what can be said in defense of this
lunacy apparently nothing at all which
is why the media has again left in
action this week not to defend the
practice but to call for critics of the
practice to be silenced on the grounds
that we're engaging in harassment and
incitement this is what christopher
ruffo uh i think aptly calls discourse
engineering and we're seeing it play out
we've seen it play out many times but
perhaps rarely as starkly and blatantly
as it has this week and it always
follows the same basic path right the
left
engages in some kind of outrageous
sickening behavior uh they get away with
it for a long time right and uh but they
keep pushing the envelope and eventually
they go too far and people notice and
then a public backlash follows
and uh but then the media comes along
and ignores the actual reason for the
backlash completely sidesteps the
criticisms that the critics are actually
making
and instead cries about harassment and
incitement
and calls on more powerful institutions
like big tech to de-platform and silence
the critics and usually they get their
way
it was announced last night that the
libs of tiktok account on facebook
has now been suspended seemingly on a
permanent basis now the ostensible
reason is that the account ran afoul of
community standards
because of its posts about the boston
children's hospital child mutilation
program
but all that libs of tick tock did of
course
is simply point out
what bch was doing and criticize them
for it
there has been once again
no effort to engage with the criticism
it is easier simply to silence them
now the pressure is falling on twitter
to follow suit and ban anyone who
criticizes or even talks about
the drugging and mutilating of children
yesterday media matters tweeted this
the daily wires matt walsh falsely
accused boston children's hospital of
putting quote every toddler who's ever
been born on a path to sterilization and
butchery before they can even talk
two days later the hospital staff was
deluged by violent threats
now there's obviously a not at all
subtle attempt here to draw a direct
connection
between my monologue that i gave on the
show a couple days ago and the supposed
violent threats against the children's
hospital
never mind that media matters actually
misquotes me which you can hear if you
listen to the clip that they themselves
posted and provided let's listen to that
today on the matt walsh show children's
hospitals around the country are
butchering mutilating and sterilizing
their young patients so according to
boston children's hospital literally
every toddler who has ever been born or
will ever be born is trans
now if it seems like they're casting the
widest imaginable net in order to catch
the most children they can and put them
all in a path to sterilization and
butchery before they can even talk
well that's because that's exactly what
these monsters are doing
and they've done it up until this moment
without much resistance from the public
but that has to end
we have to stop making it so easy on
them
and that's why i'm in the very early
stages of trying to organize a national
coordinated effort
to fight back against this evil
you know it's really just a matter of
where do we begin maybe we begin at
boston children's hospital
boston children's hospital says its
staff is being threatened and harassed
now after far-right activists on social
media posted misinformation claiming
they performed gender affirming
hysterectomy procedures on young girls
the hospital says it's not true they do
not perform those procedures for anyone
under the age of 18. boston children
hospital says it is proud though to be
home to the first pediatric and
adolescent transgender health program in
the united states the hospital though
now is working with law enforcement to
try to better protect its staff in the
face of these lies
lies yeah uh once again the obfuscation
well we don't do that we don't do that
procedure
yeah but you are taking
young girls and you're chopping the
breasts off that's what you're doing
and you're chemically castrating kids
that's what you're doing
no we don't remove their we don't remove
uh their uteruses we just cut their
breasts off and sterilize them that's
all we do that's all we're doing to kids
no big deal
now media matters quotes me as saying
that um
boston children's is putting every
toddler who's ever been born on a path
to sterilization and butchery before
they can even talk
in reality i said that boston children's
is casting a wide net catching as many
children as they can and putting them
all on a path to sterilization and
butchery the difference in those two
claims should be obvious
they're not doing it to literally every
child on earth as much as they might
want to i don't know
but they're doing it to as many kids as
they can
which is true
media matters has to lie about what i
said because they can't argue against or
deny
what i actually said
they can only demand that i'd be
punished for saying it
this has also been the strategy of
brianna wu who's the uh you know the
gamergate chick and she was on a tear
she's been ontario for the past 24 hours
demanding that ibd platformed on the
grounds of incitement this morning she
ranted matt walsh is going to get
someone killed twitter should suspend
him for inciting violence if you want
evidence just look at my mentions from
from him yesterday these are the same
violent nut jobs that murdered george
tiller for providing abortions
a show on twitter doesn't phase me but
calls for violence and dehumanizing
healthcare workers is a different story
this is screaming fire in a crowded
theater and twitter shouldn't facilitate
it someone is going to get killed
now i never called for violence
obviously
there's a reason why
among all the claims that i've called
for violence and others have called for
violence no one's quoted us calling for
violence
did you hear that in the media matters
clip
do i tell anyone to go do anything
violent
of course not
she's also lying you know all these
people can do is lie because again they
they absolutely cannot engage with the
point they cannot defend the practices
that i and so many others are
criticizing
i went back and forth with brianna for a
while um asking her if she could
actually offer some sort of defense or
justification for giving double
mastectomies to teen girls chemically
castrating pre-pubescent boys
she couldn't defend it
and instead kept repeating like some
kind of incantation that i'm committing
incitement
you know it's a it's actually
i am speaking out against violence i'm
speaking out against the violence being
done to children
people like brianna woo and media
matters and all the rest of them on the
left
are defending violence against children
and trying to silence anyone who speaks
out against it
but you know if criticism is incitement
then it must be said that brianna wu is
inciting violence against me media
matters
is the most guilty of this
media matters are certainly guilty of
incitement
in fact media matters has been attacking
me relentlessly for years they've been
attacking everyone here at the daily
wire for years
they're obsessed with us they want to
date us they either wanted data so they
want us killed or both maybe
you never know with these freaks
they are guilty of harassment and
incitement by their own logic
and of course in their case it's it's
there's there's actually
much more of an argument to really be
made for that
because they're lying about us they're
lying about what we're saying
and they're going around claiming that
uh that we are you know a physical
threat
so by their logic then they are guilty
of incitement but what we know
of course is that the incitement charge
is only ever made to silence
the opposition
and that obviously is what this is all
about
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you've heard me talk a lot on this show
about how important it is to get your
kids away from the public school system
and mainstream kids content uh that's
because marxism socialism critical race
theory trans ideology all of that stuff
is out there the left is pushing a
persistent and loud attack on the truth
and they're starting with your kids
there are a lot of ways you can protect
your kids from these not so secret
leftist agendas you can homeschool you
can get them involved in a religious
community you can give them the right
books to read like my best-selling
children's book johnny the walrus at
johnnywalrus.com but one of the easiest
and simplest ways to protect your
children is to take five minutes tonight
to write a will with epic will a will
gives you the power to say who will
raise your kid should something happen
to you and your spouse it can in certain
cases be the only legal defense standing
between your kids and the persistent
indoctrination attempts from the left if
you don't have a will you're allowing
the state to decide everything who gets
to raise your kids who gets your money
everything and they can hit your family
with a massive fee for administering on
your behalf don't let that happen
go to epic will epigle is an online will
platform that costs less than your next
trip to the store they can set you up
with a will in as little as five minutes
starting at just 119 plus you can save
10
when you go to epicwhale.com and use
code walsh take five minutes tonight to
write a will ensuring that your kids
will be raised the way you've intended
in the event that something happens to
you go to epicwheel.com and use my code
walsh today
all right i actually want to start with
this um just because it's kind of fun
yesterday we showed some some images uh
still images posted by congressman
thomas massey of an irs
recruitment session and uh you can see
how the irs is you know recruiting a
bunch of agents to use lethal force
against people who claim too many
deductions on their tax returns or
whatever
but the problem for the agency is that
the recruits are about as physically
impressive
as like a jv badminton squad with all
respect to badminton um so massey had
photos from the recruitment but but
today we have the actual video footage
of this recruitment session which is
even better so let's go ahead and
let's go let's watch some of this as
they're recruiting the okay
they're busting into the place
because someone didn't claim 492 dollars
worth of uh
sales on etsy on their taxes or
something
sir you counted a dinner at red lobster
as a business expense sir we're taking
you in
the bmi index going on here
oh this guy's trying to talk himself out
of it
i'm not saying the thing sir
we're not having any of it though
all right you know what just
just shoot the guy just shoot him
he sold a coffee table on ebay
and didn't claim it on his taxes just
take him out
and this guy over here look at this guy
here
okay they're taking them in
they've got like five people with guns
pointed at his back
who is this guy john wick
did john wick make some suspicious
deductions
all right so there we go
that's what the irs is doing
you know the thing is
i said yesterday half joking that this
should make us feel a little bit better
we could turn it off
this should make us feel a little bit
better about the 87 000 agents that
they're that they're hiring especially
because you know as i said yesterday if
they come to your house
with guns they're probably going to end
up just shooting each other by accident
but at the same time
um the fact that
the the tyrants are this physically
unimpressive is is even more
demoralizing in a certain way
it's somehow even more psychologically
demoralizing
that in our you know
in our country today
the the the petty tyrants running the
country are just it's like this the most
unimpressive
mediocre people imaginable
are the tyrants
ruling over us
which in some ways is even worse
you would almost prefer if they were a
bunch of like navy seals types
all right um this is from nbc so
i'm just going to read the report
um an update on the monkey pox outbreak
which may or may not come as a surprise
to you it's from nbc it says since the
outset of the global monkey pox outbreak
in may public health and infectious
disease experts have told the public
that the virus is largely transmitting
through skits transmitted through
skin-to-skin contact in particular
during sex between men
now however an expanding cadre of
experts has come to believe that sex
between men itself
both anal as well as oral intercourse is
likely the main driver of global monkey
pox transmission the skin contact that
comes with sex these experts say
is probably much less of a risk factor
in recent weeks a growing body of
scientific evidence including a trio of
studies published in peer-reviewed
journals as well as reports from
national regional global health
authorities has suggested that that
experts may have framed monkeypox's
typical transmission route precisely
backward
re-conceiving the primary risk factors
for transmission is crucial because of
how it may affect guidance on reducing
the risk of infection including the
question of whether demanding that
people with the virus self-isolate has
any substantial impact on transmission
so now they're finally months later
they're finally admitting that oh you
know what this is actually basically
an std
this is a sexually transmitted disease
after claiming for months that it wasn't
that uh yeah it's almost all gay men
getting this and uh and it tends to be
transmitted
at orgies and that sort of thing
um
and it's you know gay men who have uh
14 different sexual partners over the
course of a weekend they're the ones who
are contracting this but it's not an std
it's not it's got nothing to do with gay
sex at all it's just it's it's really
skin skin contact that's what they told
us
and now as nbc is emitting well that's
precisely backwards
and as always
they they want to get away with this
um
by saying well we didn't know before so
we're just learning as we go along well
no but you did know before
you knew before because i knew
okay i'm not a public health expert i'm
not a doctor
i knew because i just have common sense
we all knew
if if we can see this is a disease that
is spreading almost entirely in the gay
community
and that it spreads almost entirely
among men who are having sex with each
other
pretty good indication this is a
sexually transmitted infection
never made any sense to say well no it's
just skin-to-skin and you know well
okay well if that's what it is then why
then
it's
why is it only
transmitting among gay men
what about straight people who have sex
there's skin and skin contact involved
there too
and what about other environments where
there's a lot of close quarter physical
contact
about people going to concerts or you
know in any kind of really uh
crowded venue
where they're brushing up against each
other
if it has nothing to do with sex then
you should see monkey pox outbreaks
happening in all those kinds of
environments but you never did because
it was obvious from the beginning that
this is a sexually transmitted disease
among gay people
which now they finally tell us
because they have to they have no choice
but
this does put
a little bit of a different light on
some other recent monkey pox related
stories like this one for example from
the hill do you remember this it says a
medical journal has published evidence
of the first suspected case of human to
pet transmission of the monkey pox virus
a dog living with two men in france who
were infected with the virus beginning
exhibiting symptoms 12 days after they
did the four-year-old male italian
greyhound which had no previous medical
disorders tested positive after showing
symptoms such as lesions and postulates
on its abdomen
now at the time
the two uh
gay men apparently who
somehow passed monkey pox onto their dog
they said that it was because they were
co-sleeping with the dog they had a dog
in bed
but now the public health authorities
are telling us that uh just skin to skin
or in this case skin defer contact
that's not enough
it is primarily through
i don't
know i mean how do we connect these dots
do i need to spell it out
it's primarily through sexual contact
that this thing is spread
and these two guys gave it to their dog
yeah and even more horrifying than that
actually is uh the stories we've also
seen of children
who are living with adults that have
monkey pox and end up getting monkey pox
themselves
yeah i mean if we lived in a country
that cared at all about kids cps would
be breaking into those homes right away
and carting those kids out
because
this is clear evidence of uh horrible
things happening in those homes
all right
let's go here this is uh former
president former vice president rather
mike pence who does have ambitions of
being president one day spoke out
yesterday
at an event
about the anti-fbi sentiments on the
right and he what he says is that
hey we've as as conservatives we've
criticized the defund the police
movement well pence says let's not
replace that with defund the fbi because
that's just as wrong-headed
let's listen to him make that argument
i also want to remind my fellow
republicans
we can hold the attorney general
accountable for the decision that he
made
without attacking rank and file law
enforcement personnel at the fbi
the republican party is the party of law
and order
our party stands with the men and women
who serve on the thin blue line at the
federal and state and local level
and these attacks on the fbi must stop
calls to defund the fbi are just as
wrong as calls to defund the police
the truth the matter
is we need to get to the bottom of what
happened
we need to let the facts
play out but more than anything else
the american people need to be reassured
in the integrity of our justice system
and the very appearance
of a recurrence
of politics playing a role in decisions
at the justice department demands
transparency as never before and i will
continue to call on the attorney general
and the justice department to make that
information available to the american
people and do so now
i totally agree with what mike pence
said
at the end of his statement there where
he says that we need to be reassured in
the integrity of the justice system that
certainly we do need
um because when you have a society that
has completely lost faith
in the justice system completely lost
any faith that that there that there is
a system in place
for enacting and exacting justice well
then you have the collapse of society
so this is a this is of critical
importance
to
reassure the american people about the
integrity of justice
well how do you do that
you do that by taking these kinds of
agencies
and
disassembling them i mean ripping them
down ripping them apart
um
right down to the you know right down to
the foundations
and then rebuilding
so that's the difference
the reason why people are talking about
defunding the fbi overhauling the fbi
abolishing the fbi however you want to
put it whatever whatever whatever
the the exact demand is
the reason for that is that the
corruption
in these institutions
goes all the way down to the bottom and
the top i mean it's it's pervasive
that's how deep the rot is
and you're not going to get you're not
going to address the problem by just
sort of circling around
the perimeter of it
you can't work around the edges
you know people have
there's no faith in the fbi as an
institution that's the point and there
shouldn't be
the fbi is a corrupt institution
and that's the thing that mike pence
doesn't seem to understand
and a lot of other republicans don't
understand
but the republicans that don't
understand this are not going to have
much of a future in politics because
most conservatives do understand this
and we want to be represented by
republicans who understand it
take the corruption seriously
all the talk we heard about drain the
swamp and all of that uh yeah that's
that's we need that
that's great but we need it to actually
happen now
and draining a swamp is a drastic move
but that's what's necessary
because these institutions are corrupt
to their core
um
and that should be our concern much more
than protecting the feelings of the rank
and file fbi
you know the other difference too
between the fbi and like local law
enforcement
um
it's pretty clear
to any reasonable person that we need
local law enforcement like in in a in a
community you need to have local cops
so that's pretty clear and if there are
problems with the local police like
there is down in uvalde texas they're
obviously serious they're serious
corruption and problems with the local
police there and that needs to be
addressed and taken seriously but what
you can't do is just get rid of the cops
you can't do that it doesn't you can't
do it
because then anarchy ensues
that's you know that's that's the that's
law enforcement
and if you don't have any mechanism to
enforce the law then the law might not
exist
and uh if you don't have
law then you don't have you don't have a
society
certainly not a civilized one
so that that's the the first and
foremost reason
why defund the police was always an
insane idea because you need the police
and despite what you're told about from
from the left you cannot replace cops
with social workers replace them with
therapists
what about the fbi though
do we need the fbi
at this point
that at the very least is an open
question
okay the fbi
has to fundamentally justify its own
existence to us
to begin with
there are so many federal
law enforcement agencies there are so
many federal agencies and then and then
departments within agencies that have
given themselves the power to enforce
laws to use deadly force i mean as we
just reviewed even the irs now as a
criminal investigations division
they're sending the people out with guns
so while the necessity of local law
enforcement is clear to any thinking
person
[Music]
when we look at the federal government
and their law enforcement agencies and
how there are just like dozens of them
overlapping each other
i think now we can look at that and say
well how many of these do we actually
need what are all you people doing
hey the criminal enforcement division
the criminal investigation division of
the irs what are you doing that isn't
already done by these other federal
agencies why do we need you
um that's an open question that's a good
question
and it's very clear that at least some
of them we don't need it all and should
just be abolished
you know we don't need 75 different
federal agencies running around with
guns
fighting the bad guys
all right let's go to this here's a
story from the daily mails from several
days ago that somehow we haven't talked
about yet and i want to mention it
because of course it's very relevant to
the news this week
it says pediatricians across america
are at war with their own professional
body over controversial puberty blocking
drugs routinely handed to teens wanting
to change gender the top child health
experts are
accused the american academy of
pediatrics of pushing the harmful drugs
on transgender identifying youngsters
according to damning leaked documents
disturbingly the documents also reveal
experts believe that the a the app
that's actually the aap is deliberately
silencing internal criticism by blocking
moves for a crucial policy review
the papers leaked by a whistleblower
expose how rank and file aap members
across the u.s are slamming the
academy's shoddy drugs and hormones
first approach to trans-identifying
teens
they insist
that many would benefit from counseling
or therapy instead oh you think
and urge the professional body to follow
a more cautious approach currently being
adopted by similar bodies in other
countries
fast-tracking adolescents into powerful
drug cocktails takes a huge toll on
young bodies and can lead to sterility
and osteoporosis osteoporosis according
to critics for many teams transitioning
is celebrated but others regret the
treatment and seek reversals
the aap for its part says that its
guidelines to reinforce the gender of
youth selects including through drugs
cross-sex hormones and eventually
surgery are evidence-based and that it's
open to collaborative conversations on
policy
but angry aap members say the academy
changed its rules to block a
member-drafted resolution to launch a
policy review um and by the way just
side note here
the ap says that its guidelines are
evidence-based
that's completely false there's really
no evidence to support any of this stuff
and that actually was in
you know i kind of whittled down the the
clip that we played of dr montano that
we played at the start of the show
um that's like i said it's a 20-minute
interview and it's worth going to
youtube until it's taken down until they
delete it's probably already deleted but
if you can watch the whole thing you
should do that
because there's another interesting
point in that interview
when he's asked about
sort of
like long-term studies
um related to
you know giving kids these kinds of
drugs puberty blockers and then
comparing that to kids who have gender
dysphoria but are not given the drugs
and like long term if you compare the
two groups uh what do the studies say
and he admits in the interview that well
there aren't any studies
we don't have any studies on that
which of course we don't because we've
never been doing this to kids before
certainly not on this scale or anything
close to this scale
so no there's no evidence there there
are no long-term studies to to to uh
validate or vindicate or
most of the things that we're doing here
or any of them
so evidence-based is a total lie
now the reason why the aap the american
academy of pediatrics has adopted this
approach and endorsed it
the reason why it's all politics it's
all ideology all the way down
they are told by wpath
which is the big transgender health
association in the world and wpath just
tells everyone what the uh guidelines
are for dealing with trans kids and then
all of the other medical institutions
and organizations dutifully follow suit
without questioning it without asking
any questions or anything
and as we see here from these
whistleblowers if anyone within the
organizations does ask questions or
raise concerns or raise any red flags
they're silenced
as daily mail says angry aap members say
the academy changed its rules to block a
member-drafted resolution to launch a
policy review it led to the review
review being sidelined at the academy's
leadership conference which ended in
chicago on monday
instead members took the unusual step of
airing their concerns in the comments
section for a separate resolution in the
aap's member only website in the
comments leaked to dailymail.com aap
members said the academy was endorsing
great harm
that its care package for
trans-identified teens was based on
scant and shoddy evidence
and that doling out drugs and hormones
was unsafe and unsustainable
one pediatrician wrote before
promulgating gender affirming care with
all of its ethical complications
irreversible body bodily changes
sterility etc don't we want to be sure
that this is the best path
another member said that there was no
good long-term outcome data for those
who undergo the arduous physical process
of transitioning
and pointed to the 37 000 members of an
online forum for regretful d
transitioners as they are known
now
it's good that these uh
um
whistleblowers are coming out and and
criticizing
but it's not nearly enough
okay to do it anonymously is not nearly
enough
and i and i understand
you know if you're a pediatrician and
you come out against the aap publicly
and you do so on the trans stuff
uh
you know you're putting your career on
the line
career you've worked hard for
spent a lot of time in school spent a
lot of money on student loans
to put that on the line that that takes
uh it takes a lot of courage
there's no understating the amount of
courage it takes to put your entire
career on the line but that is what's
required
okay so if you're a pediatrician and i
hear from pediatricians all the time
actually again never wanting to go on
the record
but they'll message me privately and say
hey i agree with everything you say on
this stuff keep saying it
so i know that there are some listening
to me right now and what i want to say
to you
is that it is not good enough
to be anonymous you have a
responsibility to speak up publicly and
put your name on it
and if you want to do that and you want
a platform if you're if you're ready and
willing
to come out publicly and speak out
against this stuff especially if you're
a member of the a the american academy
of pediatrics
and you're ready to do the right thing
with your name on it
then reach out to me
i'll make sure that your concerns are
heard
because when you voice them anonymously
on message boards and in comment
sections
and you send private emails to
conservative podcasters
that doesn't do anything
i mean you're the first line of defense
you're the people that we need
because i can i can sit here all day and
forever which i will speaking out
against this stuff
but what i'm always going to run into is
the claim oh you're not a doctor you're
not an expert
which of course is irrelevant you don't
need to be a doctor or an expert to know
that you shouldn't mutilate and chill
and castrate children all you need is
common sense and a soul
which is something sorely lacking on the
left
which explains how we got here
but whether it should or not the the
expertise and all that it it it does
matter to people
so it would be a little it would be a
lot more powerful i mean there should be
press conferences
with whole groups of pediatricians
speaking out against this answering
questions
explaining their position
talking about what's going on behind the
scenes
um
and until that happens this isn't going
to get any better
all right one other thing i gotta this
is just a
really
sort of a on a health note this is from
cnn it says early in the pandemic people
couldn't get enough pizza now not so
much
papa john's sales are still up but
growth is slowing in the second quarter
sales at its north american restaurants
open at least a year
grew just under one percent
and what that has led to at uh papa
john's
is that they're they're getting
a little bit more creative trying to
figure out how to get people to buy
pizza again
so to get people excited about pizza
again papa john's is offering a new spin
on the classic with papa bowls
that are all topping no crust
the pop-up bowl comes in three varieties
maybe i'll get a picture up on the
screen to show you so you can see these
monstrosities
garden veggie chicken alfredo and
italian meats trio and so what they're
selling now to summarize it's just they
figured like no one wants to buy their
pizza and so they say oh you don't want
our pizza we'll just put all of our
toppings in a bowl and slide there some
sauce on it and will you guys eat that
will you shovel this into your mouths
the only reason i mention this story
again it's really a public health
warning okay this is like a psa
do not eat
a dish of pizza toppings from a place
like papa john's just don't do it trust
me i've worked at these kinds of pizza
places i've never worked at papa john's
specifically but i've worked at the
pizza chain places they're all basically
the same
and i can tell you
that these toppings they're not even
real food they're made of essentially
styrofoam they come in these big plastic
bags and uh they sit out at room
temperature for like days at a time
and if they drop on the ground they're
swept up in a dust bin and just like
dumped right back into the container
i've seen it happen
and now they want to put it all in a
bowl and have you shove and shovel into
your mouth don't do it
is it just me also by the way and maybe
this is my imagination but are is pizza
getting worse
am i losing my taste for it or is it
getting worse because it seems like all
these peop these chain places dominoes
and papa john's in particular the
quality of the pizza
it wasn't great back when i worked at
these places but it seems to be getting
worse
that's a crisis we should be looking
into
let's get to our comment section
[Music]
[Music]
nobody likes to spend money on their
cars you know you buy it you drive it
you want it to run forever maintenance
free unfortunately that's just not the
way things work snap out of it get back
into reality cars require upkeep okay
the same way your house requires upkeep
the good news is that you can maintain
your car for less when you shop for auto
parts at rockauto.com chain stores have
different price tiers for professional
mechanics and do-it-yourselfers but
rockauto.com's prices are the same for
everybody and they're also reliably low
for everybody that's the best part
rockauto.com has been in the auto parts
business for 20 years family owned their
goals to make auto parts available and
affordable to keep you safe on the road
they not only have the auto parts you
need but they will give you a selection
of trusted brands to choose from the
rockauto.com catalog is remarkably easy
to navigate quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brand specifications and prices you
prefer amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts you'll ever need
rockauto.com go to rockauto.com right
now and get breaks shocks carpets wipers
headlights everything you need at
rockauto.com and be sure to write walsh
in their how did you hear about us box
so they know that i sent you
nkfd says matt gotta make your sweet
baby gang a stochastic terrorist t-shirt
you're right i don't know how we didn't
think of that we do need
i think we need that
we got to get that on there
or at least maybe maybe that's a badge
we could put that in a patch program
when you become a terrorist
um
meat lover says
i wish the dw had someone that was more
knowledgeable on guns and focused more
on them since there are things that go
on in the gun world that isn't covered
by the dw
like a lot of the stupid things
that uh the atf does i think we covered
the gun the gun issues pretty pretty
well
um
but you're right it is it is an
important you know there are
uh
i i think among conservatives it's like
we can't we can't focus on
every issue
you know you can't give special focus to
every issue
and different different conservatives
have different things that they're
especially focused on for me it's always
been culture family you know those are
the issues that i care the most about
which isn't to say that the other issues
don't matter
i just think that culture issues are
foundational
don't be woke says matt hasn't dressed
like a lumberjack in a while does his
new office
have a dress code
uh no i've just been told
in fact the way's been phrased means i
need to start dressing like an adult
and so this is my this is my
version of that
i don't know how long it's going to last
i said i'd try it out
i'll try classing it up a little bit for
a little while and we'll see how long it
lasts but
i'm not making any promises
suicide production says i initially
thought stochastic was a blending of the
words stoic and sarcastic which would
exactly define matt walsh well that kind
of terrorist i am
that i would admit mark says hi matt you
often talk about fighting fire with fire
and i respect that my question is where
do you draw the line with the left will
you always give them a dose of their own
medicine is there any tactic the left
uses that you will not use
i love this question and i took some
time to think about it is a good
question um
and and i do believe in general
that we shouldn't
be squeamish and kind of handicap
ourselves
by refusing to fight fire with fire or
use their own tactics against them
but does that apply across the borders
or is there anything in general that
they will do
um against their opposition that i would
not do against them and actually ant the
answer is yes there's one thing
there is there's one tactic that the
left uses
all the time
that i will not use
even if it means i'm you know tying one
hand behind my back essentially in the
fight and that is i won't lie
that's the one thing i won't do
um
i will aggressively confront
them on any subject
and i'm not going to be squeamish about
it but i'm not going to just make things
up i'm not going to lie
like they do
like they do against me against like
they do against all of their enemies
and the reason i won't lie is that well
first of all it's just it's not
ultimately i don't think it's a good
strategy
in putting putting the ethical and moral
question aside for a moment it's just
it's not a good strategy you weaken your
case when you when you lie
it's also not necessary like i don't
need to tell lies about them i like all
i need to do is say what they're
actually doing
and point out what they're actually
saying
um but
but also it is uh
objectively immoral
and it lessens you you know as a person
when you resort to defamation slander
and all those kinds of things
so while they're doing that to me
especially this week
as i've talked about on the show like
it's i've of course they've always done
this but this week in particular they've
gone
it's gone into hyperdrive
they're fabricating screenshots of
things i never said they're
photoshopping they're doing all of this
and um
that i will not do in return
but again no need to either
you know
i don't need to invent horrifying things
that they've said or supported
the truth is all i really need
you know whenever i get into a spat with
somebody on twitter over something that
i supposedly tweeted it's usually
because they didn't actually read what i
wrote reading is a lost art
on twitter but that's not the case on
daily wire plus ben shapiro's book club
is back tonight at 8 p.m eastern on
dailywireplus.com this month book club
is john's john steinbeck's epic east of
eden you can tune in to hear ben discuss
the novel and share his notes with you
as well you got to be an all-access
member to join in on the fun so what you
got to do first is go to
dailywireplus.com to become a member
today and join ben tonight at 8pm
eastern now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
a few months after the washington post
featured an editorial written by a
george washington university student
urging that the university be renamed
the editorial board for the university
of virginia has now taken up a similar
cause at their own school the editors of
the student newspaper which is called
the cavalier daily published in op-ed
this week calling for uva to do more in
the name of inclusivity and equity
specifically they want the memory of
thomas jefferson the school's founder to
be finally and totally erased once and
for all all mentions of him and
references to them must be destroyed
they insist
reading now from the article they say we
reject how the university's physical
environment one that glorifies racist
slave-holder holders in new genesis with
statues and buildings named in their
honor upholds an enduring culture of
white supremacy there's a reason why
charlottesville's local ku klux klan
chapter hosted its inauguration ceremony
at jefferson's monticello tomb there's a
reason why white supremacists gathered
with tortures around jefferson's statue
on the north side of rotunda there's a
reason why they felt comfortable
marching through grounds
our physical environment from statues to
buildings
building named to jefferson's
overwhelming presence
exalts people who held the same beliefs
as the repugnant white supremacists in
the attendance at the unite the right
right rally these buildings must be
renamed and the memorials must be
removed
but you know as always
this is not enough because nothing ever
is
the editors continue making demands and
here's what they say next
it's our belief that future education
about charlottesville and university
history should be two things
mandatory and continuous
all students should be required to learn
about charlottesville and the
university's racist roots and more
recent history including the unite the
right rally educating students on these
topics should continue over the course
of their four years at the university
historically the university has
contributed to displacement erasure and
discrimination of charlottesville
communities especially its black
residents individual students and alumni
replicate this harm too
jason kessler and richard spencer white
supremacists and organizers of the
deadly unite the right rally are both
alumni the university also educated paul
mcintyre the namesake of the mcintyre
school of commerce mcintyre department
of art and mcintyre amphitheater who
funded the construction of the robert e
lee and thomas stonewall jackson statues
and of course these two statues were the
same whose pending removal played a
significant role in inciting the unite
the right rally itself we cannot ignore
the reality that the university has
always played a significant role in the
lives of charlottesville residents
now we learned something important here
if we hadn't learned it already the left
is
not as they're often accused
setting out to simply erase history
now if you're not playing paying close
enough attention if you're only ever
reading the first paragraph but not
going on to the second
you may come to the erroneous conclusion
that they want to wipe away all traces
of our history and just kind of live as
though the world came into being last
wednesday it may seem on first cursory
glance that they seek to live in some
sort of time warp and some kind of void
where there is no past no future just an
eternal now
if that's all they were trying to do
it would be bad enough
because human societies throughout
history have always until ours
cherished their connection to the past
in ancient cultures this often took the
pla took the form of actual ancestor
worship
far from trying to erase their ancestors
they would venerate their ancestors as
deities
now this was a primitive approach based
on superstition not a system that i
would advocate or return to
but it was at least grounded in the
innate human understanding
that our past is important
and our ancestors have much to teach us
if only we are humble enough to listen
the ancestor worshipers had more wisdom
at least than the pretentious pampered
college students who rather than making
deities of their ancestors instead make
demons of them
and that's the important point
you know that they're not actually
erasing the past
or at least they're not merely erasing
it
they are rather replacing it
yes they want all mention of thomas
jefferson the man who founded the
institution that they're paying
thousands of dollars to attend they want
all that removed from view
speaking of the ancient past these
spoiled worthless brats see themselves
as emperors or egyptian pharaohs kind of
waving their hands and demanding that
their physical environment be rearranged
to their liking
even if it means demolishing monuments
and statues that have stood since long
before they were born
but in the void that they create
they install something else
they want a new story of our history to
be told
and they want that story to be one of
shame and guilt
they don't want us to forget our
ancestors far from it they want us to
revile them hate them dwell on their
shortcomings whether real or imagined
they want to pay tens of thousands of
dollars to the university of virginia
only so that they can spend four years
learning how awful the university of
virginia is and what an evil scoundrel
was the man who founded it
they want the story of jefferson's
myriad achievements his enduring and
positive contributions to our nation
into human civilization his greatness
they want all that to be silenced
they want all those pages ripped out of
the book
but they want his sins to remain
because that's all they want to focus on
or learn about
that's the only reason they want
jefferson remembered
or indeed anyone else in history
remembered
why
well
partially you know it's just virtue
signaling
um partially they're just abiding by the
demands of their ideology without
thinking much about it
uh they've been indoctrinated with a
simple equation which is old white guy
equals evil
and they're merely applying that formula
here
these are extremely shallow and stupid
people and their stupidity and
shallowness are factors that cannot be
overlooked when analyzing their behavior
because whatever else you might say
about somebody who can't appreciate the
greatness of a man like thomas jefferson
you must also say that such a person is
incredibly dumb
and and the fact that our nation is
giving birth to so many of these
drooling dimwits is a matter of grave
significance
but it's not just stupidity driving this
these people prowling around casually
calling for the removal of monuments the
renaming of buildings etc they're not
only brain-dead simpletons they're also
insecure narcissists
and if i were to attempt to
psychologically profile these people i
would say that aside from their
neurological deficits which are
significant and even aside from their
ideological commitments the number one
factor driving their war on our history
i think is their own feeling of
inadequacy and mediocrity
whatever else they achieve by writing
off the great men and women of history
as nothing but evil scumbags they
principally succeed in making themselves
feel better about themselves
and wherever the left is concerned what
we always have to understand is whatever
they are doing
always 100 of the time the primary
motivation is because it makes them feel
better about themselves they never do
anything or say anything if it doesn't
make them feel better about themselves
that is the number one motivation always
always
and in this case it's a clever trick in
some ways
under normal circumstances you know a
person determined to be greater than
thomas jefferson or george washington
would have their work cut out for them
it would be very difficult to climb to
higher heights
than the summit that those men reached
unless of course you cut them down
in which case you can stand taller than
them simply by standing in place
they have all at once elevated
themselves
made themselves greater in their own
minds anyway by denigrating and
desecrating everyone who came before
them
they achieved for themselves a totally
unearned sense of superiority and even
accomplishment
by erasing the accomplishments of men
far greater than themselves
it is in c.s lewis's phrase
chronological snobbery but in the
extreme
they believe themselves to be better
than all who came before them simply
because they're living today
as opposed to having lived in the past
self-delusion and narcissism
those are the things you always find
buried underneath
wherever these people are concerned
which is why they are today
canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show we head over to our members
only section
and we'll see you over there and if not
we'll see you tomorrow godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you